we were at a charity event for kids with
open heart surgery yeah that was the
whole thing I was with the band I was
singing with the band and then the bad
guy the drummer said hey you played the
drums right I go yeah you want to play a
song I go sure she'll play the song and
then I started going to the audience
people shaking my hands I'm walking I
step on his brother's toes and he's
pushing me in my back I go relax
what a profanity I said come on guys sit
back at the charity event well actually
I was he was drinking a beer I said you
wanted another beer and they go f you
and they kept going dude this is a
charity event normally I would have
knocked you out already so let's bring
it down right now you know unless I
don't want any trouble here and then
Brian came but he came just to the
defense of his brother and he said hey
you want to take it outside and have
yeah okay
but then the bosses came in and they
said yeah don't go outside with that guy
to buy to Brian so Brian didn't know who
you were no he didn't know well okay
even though it's a charity event and you
you're he had no idea who you were no
okay so I'm assuming you guys never went
outside no we never went outside